there is enough blood there's enough
death enough killing going on we have
all the evidence we need that we need to
do more
doing nothing is unacceptable that was
my guy senator Cory Booker has fought to
keep guns off the streets of Newark and
battled Congress to pass common-sense
gun reform we'd figure out how to get
rid of guns over international pancakes
let's say this plate is America
something on this plate will kill you
bacon slash guns more Americans love
bacon slash guns but too many Americans
died because of bacon slash guns so how
do we stop dumb people from eating bacon
well first of all as you are
ridiculously condemning when you call
people dumb and you insult their
intelligence all right dad I don't want
to take away their bacon or their gun
you're a Democrat right I am a Democrat
a liberal I am a guy that it could be
considered liberal in my view okay so -
so between you and me yes what are we
getting rid of the second one well we're
not going to get rid of the Second
Amendment it's something that we don't
want to do because you can't do it no in
order to make people safe we don't need
to throw out one of our constitutional
amendments yep but I mean come on how
many constitutional amendments doing
hand well we've thrown out some of the
past which I'm really happy we did get
an update these things and this is maybe
the second oldest one I think I'm
walking around here with an iPhone -
that's the fear tactics that often
people want you to believe that
somebody's gonna try to get rid of all
the guns if somebody's coming after
their guns that is not a necessary thing
more bacon flash guns please
Booker like many other Democrats felt
like his hands were tied last June in
response to the pulse nightclub shooting
senators filibuster to expand background
checks and prevent gun sales to people
on the terrorist watch list while House
Democrats staged a sit-in which resulted
in all
efforts to pass any meaningful
regulations continue to get shot down by
Republicans and the gun lobby insisting
these liberal elites are coming for your
guns the tactic has been not only we
going to not pass background check law
or close the terrorists loophole but
we're also going to take those agencies
that could be helping us to CDC ATF and
we're going to cripple them
[Music]